so what's different between a creepy  porn lawyer in a televangelist simple  one of them manipulates people's  vulnerable emotions to solicit money and  enrich himself and the other is a  televangelist the creepy porn lawyer and  his sole client stormy Daniels have  already raised five hundred and fifty  thousand dollars for more than 16  thousand diluted fans but of course they  want more they always do  stormy Daniel says she needs at least  eight hundred and fifty thousand dollars  to cover her legal expenses which of  course consists mostly of retaining the  creepy porn lawyer don't be fooled if  you encounter the creepy porn lawyer  holding up a Bible in your living room  or leading a gospel choir in your  backyard  stand back don't give him money or tryin  to toss him morsels of stale bread  escape